قبل وصولي إلى هناك ، كانت إيران
ستسيطر على الشرق الأوسط في
غضون 12 دقيقة في الوقت الحالي ، وهم يحاولون
البقاء على قيد الحياة ،
فلدينا أعمال شغب في كل مدينة ، لذا إذا كنت
تريد حقًا مواكبة ما
نفعله والحفاظ على هذا البلد  لدينا
إمكانات هائلة كما تعلمون أننا نقوم
بعمل جيد ولكن لدينا إمكانات هائلة
للنمو بشكل لا يصدق عندما
نتخلص من هذه الصفقات التجارية المثيرة للاشمئزاز
مع الصين على مدى السنوات الخمس
الماضية ، فقد خسرنا 300 إلى 500
مليار دولار سنويًا مليار لا أحد
حتى يعرف ما هو الجحيم لدرجة
أنه ينتهي ، وليس فقط الصين ، وليس
الصين فقط ، وما نفعله هو أننا نحمي
الدول الغنية مقابل لا شيء مقابل
لا شيء قد تقول إن المملكة العربية السعودية
غنية ، نعم ، وقلت لـ
ملك عليك أن تدفع ، أنا آسف لأنك حصلت على
قلم سنقوم بحمايتك ، حصلت على قلم ،
احصل على المال الذي حصلت عليه ، يجب عليك
دفعه